[Music]
good afternoon happy that I am here with
you we have been I am coming from Don
Bosco you must be knowing about Don
Bosco schools colleges we also work for
children on the street abandoned missing
children
there is another unit called Don Bosco
young at-risk forum so I come from Don
Bosco an at-risk forum from Delhi
Don Bosco our forum
it has 174 centers across India working
for various types of children in
collaboration with NGOs garment
individuals more than 110 years in India
and we are working in about 20 states or
the Union Territories caring for about 2
lakhs plus children were in need of care
and protection and in conflict with the
law and our services are on the being on
the street meeting the children who are
abandoned missing and giving them
shelter education health counseling
vocational training job placement home
placement finally setting settling them
back in the society and we also do
advocacy with the government creating
systems especially for caring of this
kind of children or the young people who
are at risk including various types of
categories young at risk
in short you know safety and growth and
development and are in need of care and
protection that is what we define as a
young at risk and there are various
categories including hiv-infected
third gender of late we have been
thinking about them trying to start some
work for them and school dropouts drug
addicts those who are you know sexually
abused physically abused emotionally and
migrants is another category we have
been looking up looking at in the past
two-three years and any other category
of young children at risk or young
people at risk we didn't include us and
when they see
and in the region where we work machine
is inspired by our founder Don Bosco
well where every child every young
person lives and grows towards fullness
of life that's our mission okay what do
we do different projects that we do that
might interest you because when I come
here I talk to you as technical person
when I go down the line to the NGOs I am
a techie
when I go down the line I had to talk
completely a different language
otherwise just they threw me throw me
out
they say you you are talking something
about a head the money that you are
asking us to invest on technology if we
could save 100 more children that's the
kind of thinking NGOs had not anymore
they are also looking for because every
work is a model that we create and it
cannot be all the problem in India we
cannot solve and we are coming to a
realization especially people working
the lie in in divorce down the line are
realizing that we need partnerships and
networks in order to solve bigger
problems all that we do is only a drop
in the ocean and a model that's a great
realization that is coming up these days
so we are working in to develop a
biometric app it's already developed
called child PPA by which even other is
saying that it is not able to track
children's biometric it has got its own
problems so we are trying to work with
the fidgets who trying to get the palm
palm biometric and then we are
experimenting in Bangalore as well as in
Delhi if everything goes well we will
integrate it with our system which is
already existing called child emesis
management information systems and
services migrant is something we started
three years ago looking at different
points where we could work with migrants
app is in the plan but nothing has
really taken off still the groundwork is
going on
JJ Elaine's is another important work we
do in the national level trying to
improve the system of Juvenile Justice
in in partnership with the garment and
also educating down the line
implementing the law as well as taking
forward the system improvement of the
system with the garment like trying to
be a linkage that's another program we
have child friendly cities I overheard
some of you talking about the what is
that the smart cities hmm in child
fields is we are developing a model of
child friendly cities in ten cities of
we this year we have started with four
cities in which we bring in one platform
NGOs government officials of the city
the people of the place children as well
as on the platform trying to understand
problem of the children on in the city
so that they are able to take care of
the children in the city making it much
more child friendly and we are telling
the smart city builders if you don't
include the element of child friend
child friendliness in the city your city
is not smart and I you a is also in
collaboration with us you are trying to
create a child-friendly environment in
the city so that children feel
comfortable and safe
that's another program Home Link network
is what I am going to be talking about
and standards of care is another aspect
of caring of children in the centers
where the children exist where they
chill children stay with us
so that we are able to give them
wonderful care for them building up
standards these are all in short some of
the work that we do across India looking
for collaboration with the a community
what what are the three problems that I
want to present to you the one is a
runaway children another one is the lost
children another one is the child care
what is the problem every day a
statistic says there are about 170 for
children go missing in India this is a
world statistics you know that the
number keeps increasing half late you
have hope you must have heard about
Bihar you know the nightmares the
children went through in some of the
NGOs how they were
even in the name of you know you want to
say that you're running a NGO for
children is frightening these days
because of even the traffickers get into
the shoes of these NGO and spoil the
name so traffickers can come in
different ways and that is the danger
for all these runaway children as well
as for the lost children and the
statistics again says one lakh eleven
thousand five hundred and sixty nine
went they were lost and about fifty five
thousand six hundred and twenty five
remain unidentified
this is a government data we are not
very sure about that data it is much
more and so this is the problem that I
am going to be talking to you today and
what is this lost child let's take the
stages in which a lost child goes
through but the lost child comes into
the street or the railway station or the
child is actually going with a parent
somewhere and then the child gets lost
it it happens it loses track of the
parents or it the child comes with some
of the friends we want to see the city
or within the city they get lost and
they are just loitering around in the
platforms of the railway stations or in
the bus stand or in the marketplaces our
staff are there we have booths even in
Bangalore bus station as well as Bosco
here in Bangalore's called Bosco under
the title Bosco it is functioning we
have booths there in the railway station
platforms as well as in our staff for
their twenty-four hours trying to
monitor if any of these children they
also educate the caring community the
platform sweepers and other people are
also educated to identify this kind of
children and bring the children to these
booths you know to the extent I heard a
story from a lady was involved in the
flesh trade you know doing prostitution
she identifies sometimes girls whom her
superior who take and then put her into
prostitution she would rescue and tell
the child don't be here it's very
dangerous
only the life which I am living that
go to that booth they will help you out
so that's how the society is interested
in picking up these kind of children and
bringing them to safety trafficker also
they they are also present on the street
trying to pick up this kind of children
so when the child comes into the NGO or
the caretaker is identified the ban in
you or the public they are making effort
in searching for the child and their
parents when the child who is lost comes
to you most of the time the child will
tell you you know uncle I am from that
temple no there is a temple I am from
that near that temple is my house
you know aunty I you know we are coming
from school the name of the school
hardly fused few words few sentences
which is what the child will remember
and then the NGO worker has to start
tracking who are these NGO workers they
are just simple graduates maximum or
tenth pass at plus-2 pass this is what
the Hindu can effort so these people are
able to that are able to track these
children and then with these little
information that they give they go to
the website they google they search for
the police station they look for the
complaint they tried to send them back
in the meantime the parents are going to
the nearby police station and then they
are going and lodging a complaint and
they are trying to search for the child
maximum the police will receive the fyr
they file and if I are mostly they don't
do our on the record says about 60 to 70
percent of the people who lose their
children don't file in a fire first
information report with the police
because they are afraid of the police if
they're ordinary people if they are rich
people police will go around the line
search for the child otherwise nothing
happens the F IR sleeps in the database
of the police and the NGOs whatever the
information about the child which they
are collecting it is sleeping in the
database of the child yes
they also know which is the child who is
lost and they know with the child how
they can we know or the child they have
their own strategies as the NGOs have
their strategies the child you know
child is lost and so it falls prey to
this kind of trap that they set and so
gets into the problem that's why the
timing the child the time the child
lands on the street till it is rescued
is that very crucial time we need to
spend in order to rescue the child have
an answer to your question it is it's
winning over the child is their strategy
by giving a suite by promising work by
promising to take them back home if the
child is crying whatever if the child is
addressing is the answer that they will
give accordingly yeah yeah so there is a
information about the child is lying in
the database of the NGO the information
of the complain is lying in the database
of the CWC or the police cwz does not
have its own database which is
functional and the parents are searching
and other NGOs of might they might even
go into some other NGOs and give some
complaints and it is the database also
is there lying all separated not United
in any way and the challenges for this
lost child is how we can reduce the time
in restoring the child the child tells
you few words with that how we can
search the police station or the
database how we can connect that's a big
challenge how can we help in tracing the
parents or guardian while the words with
the words uttered by the child it will
just tell you school the child will tell
you school or temple or sweet shop or
bust and friends name father's name
mother's name these are all minimum you
could get and how we can connect various
databases this is a big challenge that
we have and how can we make the
distributed data of child available to
police and CWC the child welfare come
in each district who can make a decision
to get the child back and the analysis
report for the NGOs take action which
area more children are coming and which
area how we can solve the problem etc
yes it depends that's why I said there
is a lost child there is a runaway child
the lost child won't go home a runaway
child does not want to go home because
of smaller problems our fight at home
possibly so the time factor in taking
the child back home is a big challenge
last year in Chennai for example we had
a child from Chhattisgarh 9 years ago
the child came to the NGO they made
effort they took the child once or twice
to Chattisgarh they could not identify
the child's place okay so they put him
back here educated in in Tamil medium
the child reached up to 9th class the
child every year would reveal some
information with that they made effort
effort when he was in 9th class they
trace the parent yeah
after 9 years or 8 years it's a joyful
event but the child has already studied
in Tamil medium and he cannot go back to
shut this guy so this is a challenge you
know what is the mistake of the NGO they
couldn't help it out and the parent has
tried but the database is the
information is not connected and so we
are not able to settle it back home such
stories do come up every year in every
city ok and the type of number of
children who come in for example it's
easy how much a NGO can employ NGO gets
40 children in Bangalore for example 40
to 60 new children come every day into
the city and counseling 40 to 60
children what is a challenge and the
amount of time that is spent these are
all challenges that we need to restoring
a runaway child runaway child will come
and change everything of his identity
the child comes to the street so it is
lucky that you are able to identify and
bring the child home and then when you
start counseling if he is if
is from a Muslim community you will say
I am James he will change his name he'll
change his religion what is your name I
am Rama but he must be Mohammed actually
afton after 16 years we found out that
one child was a Muslim nada Hindu this
is how they will change they'll change
their identity they'll forget their
identity also so this is a challenge
they're in this place of a runaway child
collecting a biometric and identifying
possibly is a solution that's why we are
running a experiment with this biometric
and this disputed eyes other is having
its data but how we can connect it very
difficult and then humbling as its own
data track child has its own data Khoya
pi has its own data all these are having
independent data not connected but they
are willing to join hands in order to
solve the problem the challenges is
again which biometric will work for the
children other says it will not work so
what is their solution can we not create
a common platform in which all these
biometric can be tested out this is what
we had been discussing per first two
years with Microsoft and some solution
or some model as emerged we have not yet
implemented can they a platform provide
enough data for the counselor to
identify the child and help the child to
get back home soon
because the pattern in which the
children talk sometimes it is the same
so can this a I give the counselor who
is an ordinary person with a degree we
should be able it should be assisted in
order to identify what category and what
are the problems this child is saying
and what possibly in the experience that
we have with the data whatever is the
solution can AI provide data to assess
the problem of the child based on his
behavior reaction words used and
accordingly to the counseling and
correction process is a challenge and
the care in projection the third problem
yes one minute I'll finish the care in
protection is again there are we need
the child is staying with us he may be
often and it has nobody we know that he
is nobody and so we start
in care of the child but whatever may be
the situation in a particular place like
Bangalore they may be very innovative in
taking care of the child on physical
development social emotional
intellectual spiritual care etc all
these level each one will be innovating
but all these innovation will lie within
one in geo suppose these all get
formulated into a kind of analysis and
we are able to identify these innovation
and put it as a standard for the whole
of India or the whole of the world and
then measure accordingly whenever you
ask a few inputs that NGO people are
ready to get and feed it inside and with
that every quarter we are able to assess
and say this child is not okay
emotionally this child is not okay in
the knowledge wise and then take
measures so when we are giving able to
give them feedback they will always act
there there is every chance that there
is a corrective measures so with the
data available
can we not provide this this is a
challenge can we check with few input
variables whether the child is
progressing in all forms of growth can
we create standards what are the new
challenges that are emerging with it
because every year the type of children
who come and the type of challenges that
they throw is new and the measures
corrective measures cannot be same so we
have with us about 3 lakhs data in our
database in the past 6 to 10 years we
have been working with Visual Basic
starting with the B Basin which will
basically have been having databases and
now we have in Microsoft Azure platform
also data about 3 lakhs we have and we
have home placed about 1 lakh hard and
institutionalized about 67,000 they are
in contact about 13,000 all these has
only entered data not all the NGOs enter
the data
this is enter data but the actual work
is enormous and the children who died
also these data also we are able to
maintain and the missing complaints we
have received in our Institute's across
India we have about 8,000 338 traced
complained received is about 19,000 300
so we are able to
with our own manual systems of search
etc we are able to solve this problem
this is the design that has been
proposed by Microsoft we have been
working with one of the in in us with
one of the guy so he was suggesting to
us if you go with this design you'll be
able to connect the database we are
still dreaming about it hope to access
their data how useful has it been our
experience with police has been varied
because some states they're quite open
some states they say we have our own
database because each one is married to
their own data that is why we came up
with a shared model and and each
database has its own specifics
see for example BB a batch Manmatha one
Dolan they have a specific data on on
child labor we don't need all that for
identifying children we need only few
elements police have lots of other
information which is not required for
identifying the child so we are only
dialoguing with them and saying we don't
need to share everything you don't need
to share common elements which will be
helpful for identification we think that
with this process it will be possible
some police some states they have been
very very helpful in in implementing
together yes
manglu for example we share data at
least in Excel form this they keep
sharing among each other the two
databases talk
you
[Applause]